lunchtime in the center of rio de
janeiro and workers at the soup kitchen
are busier than expected despite a
turnaround from the economic downturn
during the height of the covid19
pandemic
brazil is experiencing a surge in the
number of people living on the streets
we're facing a record 12 percent yearly
inflation which has doubled the price of
food in cooking gas many retirees have
lost their homes because they can no
longer survive on meager pensions even
young people who are back at work sleep
on the streets during the week because
they can't afford paying public
transportation every day and depend on
us for a free meal
in order to deal with the rising numbers
congress approved president bolsonaro's
plan to increase handouts for poor
brazilians with just three months to go
before the general election critics say
the measure is a scheme to boost his
re-election chances
polls show bolsonaro trailing behind
former president louisiana
brazilian legislation limits public
spending especially during an electoral
year but president bolsonaro was able to
bypass the ban by convincing congress to
declare a state of emergency until the
end of the year
antoino da silva is an unemployed car
mechanic he receives 74 dollars a month
from the government that handout will
increase to one hundred and ten dollars
in august
if bolsonaro thinks this will make me
vote for him he's wrong if he really
wanted to fight poverty he would have
invested in education health and jobs
instead of campaigning in favour of
arming the population with guns he
thinks he can trick us with emergency
aid which will only last until december
bolsonaro's allies justify the state of
emergency saying brazil's economy has
been hit hard by the war in ukraine
since the start of the war fuel prices
have increased
taxi and truck drivers will also receive
government handouts to fill up their
tanks
it's more of a political emergency than
an economic one bolsonaro will increase
the value and the number of handouts
until his first term is over then what
we've seen this film before and it does
not have a happy ending
during the pandemic government handouts
were also increased to 110
between march and august of 2020 the
number of poor people declined
dramatically from 65 million to 42
million helping bolsonaro's popularity
but once the emergency aid stopped in
january of 2021 poverty rates soared
today 75 million people in latin
america's largest economy live in
poverty manika yanaki of al jazeera rio
de janeiro